Film Courage: Flawed character versus a
train wreck or is that what we want to see?
Peter Russell: Yeah, we want to see everybody
train wreck.
You want to see everybody in a room grappling
with their flaws.
I mean in a story like Madmen everybody had
a deep core wound.
Peggy’s core wound is that she’s a woman
in a man’s world but she thinks like a man.
She was damaged deeply.
Joan has deep core wound I’m only a sex
object, right?
And by the way, these didn’t heal right?
At the end of the show Joan is still dealing
with the fact that she essentially whored
herself out with this car executive and is
not taken seriously by men, yes?
They never heal but it is the core wounds
that when they bump up against each other
in the story that makes you wanna watch them
and audiences never need to know this.
But if you ask yourself why a character is
interesting you’re looking at it’s almost
always because of that.
How are they bleeding, right?
The other thing done did because he was unlovable
was he made up an entire story about who he
was he took someone else’s identity, yeah?
He took the identity of a guy who was killed
in Korea.
Again I’m not lovable.
I couldn’t be loved for me.
I gotta be somebody else.
So it’s always there in a great story.
There’s never a story that it’s not.
Another spin that wasn’t true twenty years
ago but we become a more sophisticated audience
in the United States.
We really do want depth of character that
we didn’t need twenty years ago and that’s
only going to continue.
A story like Louie, which is a television
series with this great comic, it’s nothing
but him bleeding every week in surprising
ways.
Confessing things that sort of make our teeth
be set on edge but it’s compelling to watch
someone confess.
Confession is riveting.
Whenever I confess a personal wound of mine
in the classroom, everyone is talking and
I’ve been talking a long time, everyone
just stops.
There is total silence in the room.
They’re looking at me, they want to know.
And this is why you can’t lie about your
core wound because that’s what people want
to know…”Oh…jeez…I can’t say the
truth…so..I’m going to making something
up….uh?
My mom molested me when I was four…?”
You can’t make it up.
Why because we have infinitely good bullshit
detectors as audiences.
We will know I can always tell in a the story
when someone’s telling me something that
isn’t true or isn’t their experience.
We know immediately.
You’ve got to tell the truth or audiences
will be bored.
So whatever your pain is you can’t lie.
It’s the truth that makes people want to
watch you.
Film Courage: Why do we love confessions?
Peter: Well….let me ask you.. what’s
your deepest most personal, embarrassing secret?
Film Courage: I’ll tell you when the cameras
are off.
There is more than one.
Peter: Exactly….exactly but if you were
to tell me now I would love hearing it, why?
Film Courage: My only sense would be because
then you could measure your own (secrets/wounds)
against what I’m telling you and then go
“I guess I’m not that bad after all.”
Peter: Or, “I’m not alone.
You’re in pain.
So am I.
Now I understand you.
Now I empathize with you.
Now you’re like me.
Now it’s a story about me.
It’s not some wonderful person who’s leading
a perfect life that I might fantasize about
and enjoy as a reality show, or a Kardashian
show, but it’s the deeper part of our
lives which is “I’m in pain.
I don’t have everything I want.
Are you like me?
Oh my God, you are now.
Thank you.
Now I will follow you.
Because if you can get better I can get better.
Empathizing with the character is all about
confession.
If you’ll notice in a straight story, confession
of your core wound or showing the core wound
is something that happens almost immediately
in great stories.
You want to show the character’s wound and
his compensation often in the first 10 minutes
of the show and in a movie that’s certainly
true.
The quicker you show it, the better the empathy
will be for the audience.
Don’t hide it.
And every scene is about it.
Every scene is about the core wound and about
how you’re either curing it or making it
worse.
And every character in a movie is only ripping
at the wound or healing it.
That’s all it is.
Movies are just….think of a movie story
as a boxing ring and the hero jumps into the
ring but he’s bleeding.
He starts out bleeding.
And the whole movie is people jumping in with
bandages to help him heal or people jumping
in with knives to rip it wider open.
In a television story that just continues
for season after season.
But it’s the same thing.
QUESTION FOR THE VIEWERS: What character,
movie or TV show does this conversation bring
to mind?